welcome back to pooh detective tonight's
investigation our Disney theme parks the
crappiest place on Earth all right cat
yeah Disney World has apparently been
hit with so many people pooping while
waiting in line for rides that cleaners
now have a special code to alert them to
human
feces as someone you're iconic in a way
for poop related trials and tribulations
do you have any tips for the the uh uh
uh Park
goers um I will well what happened to me
was different I was
[Applause]
like bring a bag I had an ostomy I know
but I also was able to not let nobody
knew it yeah cuz I was keeping it
contained yes so I also wasn't going on
roller coasters during that time in my
life but could couldn't they sell
something called the tinth which is like
a little portable bag um I mean if they
wanted to name an OS bag after me I
would be completely fine with that I
would love that actually maybe that's
what I'll do like those influencers all
come up with like hard seltzers yes I
can do that instead yes um I also just
wonder this is probably not that this
could maybe be kids yeah I hope it's
kids hope it's not like single men in
their 40s that are
line well that's happened to me a few
times I'm not going to
lie all right I am
lying Joe uh save me Greg you're not
you're not in your 40s anymore
um you
know I think Disney is loving this this
news story they love that this is out
there because what Disney does is they
make the amusement park experience so
terrible with really long lines and then
someone there had an idea hey you know
how the lines are terrible well we can
make money off the lines being terrible
by selling a FastPass well now there's
another reason to get a FastPass you
don't want to step in human poop yes yes
yes they're GNA how soon Tyrus before
they sell like a $100 bottles of FaZe in
the gift
shop that would make sense Greg so
that's not going to happen um they would
how did we get here like
pretty simple like you I get when you're
two and three you struggled with it you
know Mom it was Mom and Dad or whomever
or whatever T you to be potty trained
and then you kind of learn it was like
this magic room for whenever that
happened and usually pretty much
everywhere and you can even set your day
like hey I'm going to go before I get to
the park yeah you know or right after
lunch like hey bath and break then we'll
go or you even say hey Cat you mind
saving my place I really got to go okay
Tyrus at no point would it be like hey I
really want to get on this roller
coaster hold
on Yo cover me there's a weird guy
looking at me over there and everybody's
okay with this and Cat it's not children
because children would be in diapers or
if someone did everyone be like oh he
had an accident and they'd rally around
him and help him get cleaned up in the
bathroom these are grown ass men and
women with the Mickey Mouse hats on it's
that group that we hate yeah that's who
it is that are doing this because and we
all know where they're coming from every
one of these are all San franciscans
coming because it's the way of life now
where in New and if you're from New York
the only place that you can go and be
safe and have plenty of room is a
bathroom these days public restrooms are
wide open because it's not worth the
trip when you can just drop tral and
wherever you're at it's true it's like
the 2020s have become will be forever
known as the era that pooping went
public Brian I heard I don't think
that's
true make me I just want to believe that
okay you know I heard that Disney's now
creating a new ride called I think it's
called pirates of the
colon I um I said to myself when I read
this story are we really going to put
this on the show yeah and then I said
what kind of question could Greg ask
about this and the third thing I said is
I've been to Disney way too much this
doesn't happen I don't believe this how
often do you go to Disney yeah what's
what's I've probably I probably been to
Disney 15 20 times why well I mean I
bring my I know I bring my team my
soccer team there they play soccer
tournaments there when they were all
playing and number two is my family
loves Disney uh I don't really but I've
never seen that and I've seen long lines
I don't believe this story you don't
believe this story how dare you question
our journalistic ethics you know the
Pooh detective Works long and hard on
the story I mean the open was
unbelievable it I I would if I had that
open I'd make up a story to follow it
well maybe we did maybe you did maybe my
journalistic senses are a little bit
Keener than you thought when you booked
me no it's a real story I think I mean
where did we get it from anyway I can't
remember was it Disneyland in California
by anything yes Anaheim more like
Anheim thank you a smattering of
Applause up next a lot of people hate
when food gets stolen from their plat
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else